what's a Prez
welcome back to some okay buddy let's
play dice over cuny hinges to know
cannot occur pit crews do owe money
Yanik you owe me da wather look such
gonna shut up but we didn't see such
egos I was like I thought for sure he
cut off his own tongue so he wouldn't
tell anyone because she would make
someone but it makes sense cuz he was
yelling but okay Kokoro yonder coach
Agha yo CNO GK odarg a nice ability
become your SATs con una achieve our Oh
Julio Costa okay now I know okay I'm
stupid I'm sorry
well she was then such gonna coach
Darrell never can go without a bag of
tons love it Kuroko ah Soto sortation de
canoas Tania hermano porrica aurere Cara
know me tell you gamma other pirates
z-degree you skipping it ah woo hello
fancy smancy they have electricity down
here who are the saj
abandoned bomb shelter goku look honey
cool mobile go oh my god come on Dicky
oh god oh my god she's not wearing any
panties
oh my god I'm so stupid I realize now
that's why oh my god I feel so bad now
oh my god
I'm so I'm the worst I'm the worst
alright I hear someone crying no doc
where tautomer owner and a casino mono
Chennai where Ted Simeone Coco Nimoy
conduct easy Oh anyone we encountered so
far in this [ __ ] life Coulibaly
what the Frick uh-oh who is this what is
that's a lot of them that's out at him
and his hell oh there's a pattern here
that I have to follow isn't it I didn't
follow it at all here then it went here
and then he went here and then he went
here and then he went straight my god
I'm a genius
thank you thank you very much there
Shiho stay strong no matter what happens
no matter what you may see why I never
lose that immovable well of yours fight
the darkening don't let it take over if
you can't beat it then you can beat fate
itself if you look pretty I mean it's
mr. Birdwell fresh Iten man [ __ ]
camera guy the hell is he doing here
stop stupid beanies wearing
oh crap what's my style
oh my god echo okay you're not that
Madoka Slovakia probably some really
weird [ __ ] let's open this
all right I didn't even know that was a
problem but let's get to know huh that's
another one needed there nothing here
let's go down here breasts let's go and
see if when find out what's going on
another one was the point of this there
should be another one here yep
I don't see was a point for long in the
game play with puzzles that aren't even
apostles in my opinion like I don't know
maybe they have a purpose later we'll
have fun out and like a song did a date
day good day good day it's beautiful
what are those things anyway they look
like octopuses I do don't they
don't talk back to me don't argue with
me ding-ding-ding-ding-ding with sissing
it's a good old time sake here we go
another walking puzzle
all right that's easy oh never mind
aah what aah oh my god really that's the
only way to do I really have to watch it
doesn't make sense because all right I
think I got anyway there we go
wonderful life in - oh no no no no oh
dissection room that is my least
favorite type of room doing yoga yoga
you got Oh for [ __ ] sake the [ __ ] was
he doing Annie
Oh scream she not oh my God all those
[ __ ] buckets with blood there's a
large wardrobe here big enough to fit a
human being it's currently empty
interesting the table is covered in
basic metal tools that seem to have been
used on human remains there's a restless
sawing hammering sue made some custom
add-ins custom items we supposed up
bucket my old friend bucket bag okay
you get your hide so let's gain
whistling hi oh I don't like this
why don't they hide in the closet I
don't like oh it's him the [ __ ] is going
on Hermes he how hide in the Wardrobe he
had sorry English [ __ ]
Oh God Oh God well someone needs to come
down with that braving Oh
oh my god no oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's going down in the
toilet
no me da-jung no mother no mother stone
a good nun on it
you got gonna what I got on it now huh
come on you can call or see Madonna
he's a total dick I don't like where
this is going I don't like what you're
showing Oh
but on some pains my shin or oh yah
I'm back again but why pant pant
question mark we should go left I don't
know why my brain just immediately was
like [ __ ] left well thank god they're
live I would be so pissed if they're not
I'm so emotionally invested in all these
Karen right now if something happens I
oh [ __ ] because mister then I feel like
he's the character that could dad cause
he's like that bad ass in here own but
they really really work together but
then they can have a little moment
Damini is one of the bodies don't say
[ __ ] like that
Oh what the [ __ ]
King etcetera so gonna dance on Yama to
do Mo's cosas de Pury no Gio toda today
exa
buddy oh gosh she was lucky that would
have been a real pain in the ass Sheena
really that's it
alright then I'm gone beyond that wait I
didn't take a knees should I oh oh you
come up with god oh my god she ahora no
motapod me Susumu yeah she died
see you could not it you recent Santos I
go no koto vada [ __ ] isn't he eating you
cannot get all swollen
its first time I have a bit of shed of
hope on these people I always I thought
they would all [ __ ] dying you know
but instead I don't want to call the
alligator across the rainbow if you know
what I'm saying
hurry sincere so say say next Oh mrs.
otter voice get a Claro yo-yo ma
Iko sensing simple Coachella
Oh state occur
nothing says hope is clenching your
fists oh she took the right route didn't
she let go don't go na da da
now me can't die right come on see me do
nothing I gonna go mama
what the hell is going on down here
what I hope so Gaga Hodja not famous
mother money I'm ESCA so can I talk
wait she is she is she becoming one even
ones unlocking Conoco gave us pathetic I
Dakota Avicii dhoka dhoka I'm not gonna
cut up some mother cry
Kyra go Tim oh no Mego 9 de anima siento
topic on Tina I'm sorry mine was that
even mine
what is happening
let's go Yokosuka to Meccano reso ana
Dada Sarah Norris and akka wakka mikka
Dora
Coco Marie Korea naughty up Tyrion
rocket ah JA Cairo Jakarta that's gonna
go put on the accessories [ __ ] on me
more than Eva I'm gonna find me some use
yeah niche gonna find me gonna find me
gonna find missing you [ __ ] gonna find
me gonna family gonna fight me subject
bet can find me do a [ __ ]
gonna find me you come back you're gonna
fight gonna find me gonna find me you
capatch let's see what happens oh [ __ ]
there's a broad quotes hang for the
ceiling it's Yoshikazu yeah not go here
or here what are you interesting very
interesting it's so dark what is this a
sir
this was the room you got saints row me
okay it's pitch-black is that green here
Sachiko Sachiko
that sounds wonderful
come on don't do this
what was that oh my god Oh
Mila such go something she talk with a
dirty Hey what it does huh
Oh Mainichi gallo chronic gota ba yah
yah
just give her the tongue God Oh beaucoup
pirates Chavo Jimmy Chico sensei no
Georgia de cámara Manta
yeah Sensei - hungry Toshima tada Boca
sensei Tony yeah okay dorri naina
Timo Teresa kayo Toma sangoma day kilo
questions get a condo jamais oh boy Tony
Stark is dead no booze so we can see
what he saw except from a third person
maybe oh maybe it was on a balloon or
something cuckoos beams oh my god
Oh
two guys one on a bucket with their
hands tied behind their back and rope
around her neck so intense
what the [ __ ]
haha no no you know that decade that
can't be real
Oh what the actual fan that's why he was
so scared when she saw her him why you
saw her man that can't be true though
let's go go Kaizen devadutt don't mind
O'Connell Osuna it was a massacre such a
ghost tongue yes no I know how we all
know colors indeed oh yes No
believe me I can move again does that
mean it's working huh all right told noe
how she made a Mina let's go - you're
done please temperature has it oh [ __ ]
me I don't know let's change it what do
you guys miss Sachiko with makeup you
chant one time okay that was two times
three times will you guys for dance
you guys must I think I did it right but
I'm not so sure we were supposed to oh
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up tonight
Mina
you got no me guys Oh God
hi Java Santos gets super that's not
even know you know me I wouldn't call
the alligator with the rainbow if you
know I'm saying Shinohara
oh well at least she know she was
possessed
Angie so gaku who is Digga Rigga
Vonnegut oh gosh should I Camus there we
go
he's like a horse I know so don't leave
it there yeah don't touch fish much
better my buck call my buddy who's a
good girl
oh Jesus Christ is not over yet another
thought you had oh no no no my
perspective a coconut is it when you
thought I inherit a shimmy tiger oh I
must go see like that again see Union up
de música finished in with a fetid
Canoga coalesce it any Dania knows
that's cool migas not the stain you
sachika sorry that's my Japanese
surprise Oh God
we got a hurry I want to save now let's
do it
hey hey hey
detective Dan Ted Packard confession do
I have to walk out the same way signs
like the our turn of a grandfather clock
Oh God
that candy I don't remember the way oh
[ __ ] my dick out
that's disgusting when I say I think it
was yeah [ __ ] oh god we don't have a
lot of time
I don't remember we [ __ ] away it is
come on
the [ __ ] am I supposed to do with you
is it this way I don't know oh my god I
can't oh my god and like oh my god I can
I can we can bros yes we can
Gus don't make me slalom
don't make me slalom right now cuz I'm a
little bossy
come on microwave my way you read away
yes we can yes oh yes oh yeah oh don't
say it just do it please wipe a smiley
face oh wow why did I do that now what's
coming out Rebecca for you're missing
people are you me are you alright to
look at her butt all day
Oh God
Aquino Kota or Adachi konima estar aquí
la crème è che n de ni modo take ryuko
toka texta mina C bar ik o hacer con
esta loco bo commish miteta quevedo
saguni omo tigland etre yaga yaga stop
sensei mo Shinohara mo mu e solo begin
aquatic Otto how do you explain it
shouldn't they be like murder suspects
or some [ __ ] Skinner huh [ __ ] that
Cindy Doreen akuto go chorus it a name
Reina ito Motaba Sol Obama soredemo
nimita my sense palette are legit Yuri
sincerity no ni kakuni Utes na kimochi
Tito Costa Rica cha shin-soo cuckoo -
Nina no what is that
no more sick twists she knew oral
Michigan burrito surah burchenal
Kalamata doja Mabo decision a no yeah
kokumo
Raja Mikado
Cindy's mahtim Inoue Azumi karahi Nakata
Kootenai sorry Donna
that's [ __ ] oxt Mahmud essence mo uno
dos an low poly silicon MOBA Ratan Co Co
Kanishka fantasy writer girls America
our toxin Oh Thomas Chico stone
annoyance Kangas not make even more in
fact I found nurhachi such great things
in Chicago
Imam oh no bikini sons I still Akeno
code Tom oh no he no Giotto stamina
hello keno row in eater eats curry Tom
oh no she did scare Oh Rita Thomas it
achoooo sorezore no Tommy no Coco
Navarra kanashimi Estadio de Sucre no de
carro de Paseo cerca step
chapter five and why why I was I I
expected after all I [ __ ] that went down
at Alisa be a little little bit of joy
just a little banner joy
I thank God here we go now kiss please
suppose yeah woman yeah because that
yeah
Iza do it was say cos last wish after
off that perv
may her it rest in peace solution yet we
do is she mono Rhonda good yeah horrible
Shinohara no Kato any no coated oh so
she my no marriage and I go ah no me go
I am at the cigar rock ni ii o Kamini
no Chico no no no eso lo me todo que
pase anemic on Dario Cotto Katina kanata
say mboga Yanni not a sensitive oh yeah
Tiamo
this keeps getting worse huh Wow
don't don't care Adama Karuna Yoshi Naik
okay cat okay Mimi what happened she got
the text message or does it say I don't
know yep on us
I am I receive me now hello there
Monique on come on come on oh yeah buddy
sequiny mutirão irritate the see don't
you know chip oh good idea
come on there's another one oh no see
Muruga my doctor top circle Monica Edina
what do you think she must be furious
yeah they add emoticons screams earrings
nyaaaah cannot cast a panda modem
stay clear away cognize Nike Gustavo not
yet this local doc thank ya this oh oh
oh
no hard feelings
yeah
and there we go that was that the
picture they took in the beginning
because technically they weren't turned
course party fin there you go there you
go there you go
so that was cokes body brush jesus
[ __ ] christ i was intense I was a
crazy adventure I was a lot of things um
um uh watch to say I really really liked
the game I think it was really good it
really surprised me how well okay well
sorry it really finds me how unexpected
it was like I thought it would be
another cliche cannabis but I never
could guess what the [ __ ] was gonna
happen it was always something something
new and something interesting so that
was really cool it really kept you on
edge and it I think that's why you both
like youtubers I yeah I can tell he was
really into this and that's really also
for me to see cuz I was really into it
too so it's it's cool to share that
Whitney browse and then yeah it was a
great game and I don't know what else to
say
as always it's so cool to share this
experience with you bros it's really
what makes me excited and happy to be in
and to play through serious with you is
the coolest the coolest especially if
this is a good game like this one it's
really really awesome so just want to
say thank you so much for watching it
really needs a lot to me and I'll see
you in whatever next community stay
awesome Brea's love you right